[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور المباشره من تل
ابيب واحتجاجات المستمره ضد حكومه نتنياهو
تتعلق في التعديلات القضائيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه
مع مرور خمسمائه يوم على حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا
احتدام المواجهات في جبهات الشرق والقوات
الاوكرانيه تنسحب من مواقع فيزا زيلينسكي
يؤكد من جزيره الافعى في البحر الاسود
قدره ثياب على استعاده اراضيها وشويغو
يزور مواقع لتدريب جنود متعاقدين حديثا
يقول ان الكرملين هو العقبه امام تحقيق
السلام في اوكرانيا ويتوعد بمزيد من
العقوبات
بعد ايام على اقتحام الاحتلال لجنينه
ومخيمها 30 دبلوماسيا غربيا يجرون زياره
استقصائيه ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي يصف
الاجتياح بالصادم ويدعو للضغط على اسرائيل
لوقف العنف وتمسك اممي بادانه اسرائيل
لاستخدامها القوه المفرطه
واهالي رام الله والبيره والخليل يشيعون
فلسطينيين قتلتهما قوات الاحتلال خلال
الايام الاخيره
الجيش السوداني يعلن تنفيذ عمليه نوعيه
جنوبيه ام درمان ومقاطع مصوره تظهر انتقال
مئات الجنود من الشمال نحو العاصمه قوات
الدعم السريعه تعزز انتشارها على الطريق
الرابط بين اقليم دارفور والخرطوم ونائب
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني يصل العاصمه
الارتريه اسمر لبحث الجهود الافريقيه لحل
الازمه
على ارضيه علاقات متوتره وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه تواصل زيارتها للصين وتقول ان
فك الارتباط الاقتصادي بين البلدين مستحيل
ومسؤولون الصينيون يدعون الى النظر للجانب
المشرق من العلاقه بين البلدين رغم مرورها
بعواصف
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا افاق الحرب في اوكرانيا مع
مرور خمسمائه يوم على اندلاعها في ظل
احتدام مستمر في المواجهات بهذه المناسبه
كانت هناك تصريحات روسيه واوكرانيه وايضا
حديث غربي يتعهد بمزيد من المساعدات
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي مع مرور 500
يوم على الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا ما
مستقبل الحرب في هذا العام
14% توقعوا هزيمه احد الطرفين بينما راى
42% ان هناك فرصه لجلوس الطرفين الى طاوله
التفاوض بينما قال 44% ان الحرب ستتواصل
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعلات
عربيا ودوليا
اذا خمسمئه يوم على حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا مع مرور كل هذا الوقت تتركز
المعارك في الجبهات الشرقيه والجنوبيه حيث
اعلن عن معارك محتدمه في بخموت
ومارينكا في من سحبت القوات الاوكرانيه من
مواقع فيروجيا وعلى وقع القتال المستمر
يصرح الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي من جزيره
الافعى في البحر الاسود بان هذه الجزيره
دليل على ان قوات بلاده ستعيد كل جزء من
اراضيها
500 يوم مرت على بدء الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا فكيف تغيرت وغيرت تفاصيلها
المشهد في العالم باسره بعد نحو شهر من
بدء الهجوم الروسي
ركزت القوات الروسيه عملياتها جنوبا وشرقا
منسحبه من محيط كييف وجبهات الشمال الشرقي
سيطرت روسيا على مساحات واسعه في مقاطعه
لوغانسك ومعظم مقاطعه دونيتسك واجزاء
كبيره من مقاطعتي ايزابيلوجيا وخيرسون
لاحقا تمكنت القوات الاوكرانيه من استعاده
السيطره على ما خسرته من مقاطعه
جزيره الافعى قباله سواحل اوديسا على
البحر الاسود وانسحبت القوات الروسيه من
مدينه خيرسون الى يمين ضفه نهر دنيبر
معركه مدينه باخموت شرقا المعركه
الماراثونيه بين الطرفين كانت الابرز في
ساحات القتال فقوات فاجنر هي من سيطرت على
المدينه وفي معاركها بدات ارهاصات الخلاف
بين قائد المجموعه والقياده العسكريه
الروسيه وما حدث لاحقا من تطورات تصاعديه
كادت ان تصل اثارها الى موسكو
القوات الاوكرانيه استهدفت في اكتوبر
العام الماضي جسر القرن الرابطه بين شبه
الجزيره والاراضي الروسيه واغرقت قبله
اطرد موسكو لتبدا بعدها بسلسله ضربات
وهجمات بالمسيرات على مراكز ومواقع روسيه
مهمه ومثل مقر اسطول البحر الاسود وحتى
داخل الاراضي الروسيه لم يتاخر الدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا فبعد وقت قصير بدات
واشنطن ودول الاوروبيه بتسليح القوات
الاوكرانيه بالمدافع والدبابات والصواريخ
وصولا الى القنابل العقوديه ولاحقا قد
تدخل المقاتلات الامريكيه اف 16 غمار
المعركه ايضا عشرات مليارات الدولارات
دعمت بها اوكرانيا عبر حزم المساعدات
العسكريه وحدها الولايات المتحده انفقت
حتى الان اكثر من 46 مليار دولار اما
الاتحاد الاوروبي فاكثر من 13 مليار دولار
شهدت الحرب في بدايتها جولات تفاوض سرعان
ما توقفت وتمسك كل طرف بثوابت يشترطها
لعوده التفاوض موسكو تطلب اقرار وقبول
الجانب الاوكراني بما حدث من تغيرات على
ارض الواقع لجهه ما سيطرت عليه من مقاطعات
اضافه الى ضمانات تتعلق بعدم انضمام
اوكرانيا
فتصر على الانسحاب الروسي من اراضيها لكن
الطرفين وقعا ببساطه تركيه واشراف اممي
اتفاق نقل الحبوب صيفه عام 2022 كما جرت
بينهما عمليات تبادل اسرع اكثر من مره
ومع تقدم اوكرانيا بطلب رسمي للانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي اضافه الى مساعيها في
الانضمام الى النيتو توجهت روسيا لتعزيز
علاقتها الاستراتيجيه بالصين ودول اخرى
على وجه الدقه متى وكيف ستنتهي هذه الحرب
هذا وتفقد وزير الدفاع الروسي سرجي ساحات
التدريب التابعه للمنطقه العسكريه
الجنوبيه في الجيش الروسي ونشرت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه صورا وهو يتابع تدريبات
الجنود المتعاقدين في صفوف قوات المنطقه
الجنوبيه على دبابات تي 90 كما استمع
شويغو لتقارير من قاده المنطقه الجنوبيه
فيما يخص جاهزيه التشكيلات والوحدات
العسكريه المشكله حديثا التابعه لقوات
المدفعيه وسلاح الدبابات
انضم الينا
منشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني والمتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه سيدي
يوريساك اهلا وسهلا بك بعد 500 يوم من هذه
الحرب كيف ترون مالاتها كيف ترون انها
يمكن عمليا ان تنتهي
الصوت غير مسموع الصوت
غير
مسموح هل تسمعني سيدي ريساك
حسنا هل يمكن اعاده الاجابه اذا من فضلك
اظهرنا للعالم ان الجيش الروسي هو جيش
ارهابيين واظهرنا
ان قالوا انهم سيغزون اوكرانيا في ثلاثه
ايام وقد حررنا الكثير من الاراضي
والان نقوم بها هجوم مضاد في الشرق وسوف
نفوز بفضل حلفائنا لكن دائما هناك حديث عن
الصعوبات ميدانيه والرئيس بايدن على سبيل
المثال كان يتحدث عن نفاذ الذخائر والرئيس
السلينسكي كان يتحدث عن بطئ في التقدم كيف
يمكن ان تصف لنا الوضع ميدانيا
لقد قلنا ان الوضع في المعركه صعب
لان الروس كان لهم وقت كاف لبناء دفاعات
قويه جدا
وهذا ما جعل
حلفاءنا
يقررون مدنا بذخائر عنقوديه وذلك سيمكننا
من ان نخترق تلك الدفاعات هل اوكرانيا
متورطه في حرب استنزاف طويله يقف يقف
وراءها حلفاء
النيتو وبالتالي هي حرب بالوكاله ضد روسيا
وقد تستمر فتره طويله جدا
هي ليست حربا ضد روسيا هذه الحرب
بداها الروس
وروسيا هي التي ترتكب جرائم
واعمالا ارهابيه في اوكرانيا ودول حلفانيه
كثير منهم
يدعمون اوكرانيا في حربها
المشروعه نريد ان نحرر ارضنا من هؤلاء
مجرمي الحرب ودول حلف الناتو سوف تلتقي
فينيس في الايام القادمه
واوكرانيا سوف تتقبل تتلقى دعوه لدفاع
لانضمام الى حلف النيتو بعد الحرب وذلك ما
سيجعلنا اكثر قوه هل يمكن ان تنتهي هذه
الحرب بالتفاوض وهل هناك افق للجلوس على
طاوله المفاوضات في اي في الايام القريبه
المقبله
في التاريخ في تاريخ الانسانيه لا اعتقد
انك ستجد اي حرب لم تنتهي بمفاوضات ولكن
ما نراه الان هو ان روسيا
عاجزه عن الدخول في مفاوضات
هذه ظروف غير قابله للتفاوض عليهم ان
يسحبوا جميع قواتهم من بلدنا وان يتركوا
جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا وجزيره القرم
وبدون ذلك فلن تكون المفاوضات ممكنه لانه
لا وجود لما نتفاوضوا معها لذلك سنفاوض
سنستمر في العمل على هزيمه روسيا التي
تكبدت خسائر في دباباتها وجنودها
واكرر ان هذه ليست حربا سهله لان الروس ما
يزال لديهم تفوق في الجو ونحن نطلب من
حلفائنا ان يمدون بطائرات اف 16 لان ذلك
سيساعدنا في تحقيق التوازن في الجو
هذه الحرب بداتها روسيا ولكن اوكرانيا
ستنهيها بالانتصار على روسيا شكرا جزيلا
لكريساك وزير مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه حدثنا من العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ومعنا من موسكو ايفانكون
المحلل العسكري سيد ايفان كيف ترى
يعني كيف تنتهي هذه الحرب كيف ترى مالاتها
كيف ترى انها يمكن ان تنتهي وتكون نتيجتها
الواضح ان الحرب سوف تنتهي بهزيمه نظام
كيف النازي
وتحطيم وتدمير
الغرب المجتمع وقدراته الذي في الواقع
ينفق اعداد كبيره من قدراته ويقدم الاسلحه
لدعم هذا النظام من المفهوم انهم سوف
يخسروا واريد ان اقول ان في التاريخ كنت
استمع للمتحدث السابق عن التاريخ اريد ان
اقول ان في التاريخ الحربي العالمي لم يكن
هناك سابقه ان تخسر روسيا في مثل هذه
الحرب حارب روسيا العالم العالم كله حرب
روسيا وانتصرنا نابليون وهتلر والان
الولايات المتحده التي تتراس هذه العصابه
التي تعمل على الاراضي الاوكرانيه تحارب
روسيا وسوف يهزم هذه عمليه تاريخيه كان
لها سوابق كثيره روسيا سوف تحصل على جميع
اهدافها في هذه العمليه العسكري الخاصه
اما المفاوضات فانا متفق ان اي نزاع ينتهي
بالمفاوضات ولكن هذه المفاوضات سوف
تتم على اساس شروط روسيا الفيدراليه وهذا
شيء واضح ايضا تقول روسيا ستحقق اهدافها
ما هي اهدافها التي حققتها في 500 يوم
قبل كل شيء وصلت الى هدف واحد
قامت
بتعزيز مواقعها في مختلف الجبهات والان
تقوم بطحن المعدات الغربيه واعتقد انكم
رايتم كيف اشتعلت الدبابات الالمانيه
المشهوره التي كانت تعتبر من المستحيل ان
تهزم والان هي تحرق امام الجميع
والاوكرانيين حتى الان لم يصلوا الى اول
الخطوط الدفاعيه الروسيه حتى الى هذه
الخطوط لم يصلوا عن اي هجمات يتحدثون
لا لا يتحدثون عن هذا منذ شهر وفي الواقع
هم يطحنون
وسوف يخسر سوف تنتهي طاقه قدراتهم
وطاقاتهم وسوف تنتهي الحرب
بكارثه للنظام الاوكراني لان الغرب سوف
يرهق عاجلا ام اجلا لان هؤلاء الذين
احتلوا السلطه
اوكرانيا سوف ينفق جميع الاموال والمعدات
الغربيه دريسكي ذهب الى بلغاريا وكان
يعتقد انه سوف يحصل على كميات كبيره من
الذخيره التي تشابه الذخيره الروسيه ولكن
الرئيس البلغاري قال له كلا قال انه لن
يقوم بدعم ما تقوم به السلطه الاوكرانيه
والنظام الاوكراني وبلغاريا هي دوله من
دول الناتو وهذا حدث منذ يومين وسوف يتكرر
هذا بالتطور سريع
للنظام الاوكراني شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو
شكرا جزيلا اذا
ايفانوب المحلل العسكري
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان الولايات
المتحده ما زالت ملتزمه بمساعده اوكرانيا
في الدفاع عن نفسها بعد مرور 500 يوم على
بدء الغزو الروسي
واضاف بلنكن ان الحكومه الروسيه تظل
العقبه الوحيده امام تحقيق سلام عادل
ودائم في اوكرانيا حسب تعبيرهم كما اكد ان
واشنطن ستواصل فرض العقوبات على الحكومه
الروسيه واتخاذ اجراءات ستؤثر على قدره
الكريم على شان الحرب
اخر التقارير الامميه اظهرت حصيله يعتقد
من معديها ان الارقام الواقعيه اكبر منها
بكثير تفيد هذه الارقام بان ما يزيد على
تسعه الاف مدني اوكراني قتلوا حتى الان
واصيب اكثر من سته عشر الفا واصبح سته
ملايين وثلاث مئه الف قطره لاجئين خارج
البلاد وهناك عدد مماثل من النازحين في
الداخل اما عن الخسائر العسكريه التي قالت
الامم المتحده ان من الصعب اثباتها فان
التقارير الغربيه ومنها الامريكيه تتحدث
عن 200 الف قتيل وجريح روسي كمعدل وسطي في
حين تقدر هذه التقارير خسائر اوكرانيا
تقارير الغربيه تقدرها بنحو 130 الفا بين
قتيل وجريح من جنودها
في ارتدادات الحرب المستمره قال وزير
الدفاع البولندي ماريوس ان بلاده بدات نقل
اكثر من الف جنديا مع 200 وحده عتاد الى
حدودها الشرقيه وسط تزايد القلق من ان
يؤدي وجود مقاتلي مجموعه فاجنر في
بيلاروسيا الى زياده التوتر على حدودها
واضاف وزير الدفاع البولنديه ان هذا يدل
على استعداد بلاده للرد على محاوله زعزعه
الاستقرار بالقرب من
من فريس معنا الدكتور زياد ماجد والساده
العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه الامريكيه في
باريس 500 يوم دكتور من هذه الحرب ما
محصلتها بشكل موضعي
يعني حتى الان هذه الحرب تظهر من دون افق
يؤكد نهايتها قريبا حين بدات اعلن بوتين
انها عمليه عسكريه ورفض حتى استخدام عباره
حرب بهدف اسقاط من اسماه النازيون في كييف
وتغيير الخريطه بمعنى انه قال ايضا ان
اوكرانيا هي خطا تاريخي ارتكبه لمين نرى
حتى الان ان الحكومه في كييف متماسكه صحيح
ان الخسائر العسكريه الاوكرانيه كبيره
وروسيا تقدمت قليلا على العديد من الجبهات
لكن مقارنه بما كان قائما في العام 2014
ان كان بجزيره القرم او بمناطق دون باس
وغيرها التقدم ليس كبيرا باستثناء منطقه
بحر ازوف التي سطت عليها روسيا باقي
الجبهات متوازنه وهذا بحد يعد انجازا
اوكرانيا طبعا الخسائر الفادحه في
اوكرانيا وما تقدر كلفته حتى الان ب 400
مليار دولار من اجل اعاده اعمارها هي
محصله مروعه بالنسبه للاوكرانيين لكن
موسكو سياسيا وعسكريا وحتى اقتصاديا ما
زالت حتى الان في دوامه فشل
وليست نهايه الحرب قريبه كما ان الدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا في تصاعد ودول الناتو
توسعت على عكس ما كانت تريد روسيا فنلندا
انضمت السويد ستنضم قريبا اذا وافقت تركيا
وحتى الدعوات لاوكرانيا لكي تنضم صارت شبه
علنيه بهذا المعنى المحصله ان كان في
العلاقات الدوليه او في جبهات القتال او
اقتصاديا وسياسيا ليست لصالح موسكو لكنها
بالطبع كلفتها باهظه جدا بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين وقد يكون التعافي منها صعبا
عليهم هل يمكن ان تتسع رقعه المواجهات
العسكريه وما دلاله ان تقرر بولندا على
سبيل المثال ان ترسل اكثر من الف جندي مع
العتاد الى حدودها مع بيلاروسيا
بولندا بالمناسبه هي من الدول الاوروبيه
التي اصبحت موازنتها العسكريه بالنسبه
لناتجها المحلي من الاعلى وتقول التقارير
ان جيشها سيصبح الجيش الاقوى اذا استثنينا
السلاح النووي في اوروبا الوسطى والغربيه
وهذا مؤشر ايضا الى القلق البولندي من هذه
الحرب من المطامع الروسيه ومن جبهه في
روسيا البيضاء او في بيلاروسيا يخشى
البولونيون ان استمرت الحرب وطال امدها ان
تفتح او ان تصبح موضع توتر ان لم تكن جبهه
شامله كما ان الاوكرانيين الذين يقاتلون
من دون طيران يطالبون الان بمعدات اكثر
تطورا واكثر حداثه لمواجهه روسيا وبولندا
تقول انها جاهزه لارسال ما يطلب باستثناء
الطيران اي انها قد تصعد من نوعيه الاسلحه
التي تبعث بها الى كييف يكون ربما هناك
دافع بعيده المدى تستطيع ان تصيب مناطق
عميقه داخل روسيا وكل هذا يؤشر الى ان
الحرب ليست قريبه من الانتهاء المجهود
العسكري الروسي ما زال يمكن موسكو من
الدفاع عن مواقعها لكن الجهد العسكري
الاوكراني مقبل على التطور وعلى مضاعفه
العمليات
وستكون الامور براي بطيئه لان موازين
القوى لم تختل تماما لصالح طرف وهذا كله
يؤشر الى ان نهايتها ليست قريبه والبعد
التفاوضي فيها حتى الان رغم لقاء سري عقد
في نيويورك مؤخرا بين الامريكيين والروس
لم تنتج عنه ما يمكن ان تبين يعني تراجعا
في الشروط الاوكرانيون يصرون على استعاده
كامل اراضيهم التي غازتها وسطت عليها
روسيا من 2014 وحتى اليوم وروسيا لا تريد
حتى ان تقبل بتسويه لذلك سيستمر الصراع
وربما تاخذ اشكالا اخرى ترتبط بعمليات
موضعيه في اكثر من جبهه شكرا جزيلا لك من
باريس الدكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه الامريكيه في باريس
[موسيقى]
في اول زياره لوفد دولي الى جنين منذ
اقتحامها تفقد وفد دبلوماسي اوروبي وغربي
المدينه ودعس فنكون
ممثله الاتحاد الاوروبي في فلسطين هي
زياده الضغط على اسرائيل من اجل وقف العنف
ووصف العمليه الاسرائيليه الاخيره
بالاجتياح الصادم والمروع وبانه انتهاك
للقانون الدولي وكان فرحان حق نائب
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الامم المتحده قال ان
الامين العام
متمسك بارائه بشان ادانه اسرائيل
لاستخدامها المفرط للقوه في مخيم جنين
من داخل الصف المدرسي بنصف مقاعده الفارغه
بدا الوفد الدولي تحقيقه الاستقصائي
المناقض للروايه الاسرائيليه احد المقاعد
كانت تجلس عليه الشهيده الطفله سديل اما
المقاعد الاخرى فهي لطالبات لم يتمكن من
العوده الى منازلهن المدمره في المخيم
وهجروا قصرا
توغل الدبلوماسيون في المخيم صاروا فوق
انقاذ المنازل والشوارع والبنى التحتيه
وهنا كانت الصدمه
الهجوم لم يكن بهدف اعاده سياده القانون
والنظام بل كان محاوله للتدمير الكامل
لمناطق هناك شك في كونها تضم عناصر
الجراميه وبالنظر الى عدم التناسب بين
العمل العسكري والهدف المراد تحقيقه وطبقا
لقواعد انفاذ القانون دوليا فان القوه
المحتله مطالبه بضمان تناسب العمل العسكري
مع ما يمكن تحقيقه
وقد يكون ما دفع الاتحاد الاوروبي للاعلان
عن تحميل اسرائيل المسؤوليه هو حجم
الكارثه
بسمه واطفالها واقاربها قصف الاحتلال
منازلهم بالصواريخ بين الصاروخ الاول
والثاني احتموا مع اطفالهم العشره تحت
الارض في قبوا ليومين ضرب الصاروخان في
الدار عنده غرفه النوم الصاروخان اثنين
انهم يرجعوا يناموا وخالتين يرجعوا على
البيت نفسه اصلا لانه مش متاهل بس خوف
ورعب عشان الحياه خوفي رعب وكلما دخلنا في
ازقه المخيم يكتشف المزيد اكثر من 300
بيتا دمر ومئات العائلات شردت
مئات المتطوعين منذ انتهاء الاشتياح
ساهموا في تقديم المساعده
من بينها محاوله الترويح عن الاطفال الذين
يصعب عليهم النوم
21 عاما مضت على الاجتياح الاكبر الذي
نفذه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في المخيم
واليوم في ظل الغضب الشعبي من غياب الفعل
الدولي يؤكد الفلسطينيون ان ما هدم
يعمر ونجيلا جديدا سيواصل
مقاومه الاحتلال
الجزيره من مخيم جنين معنا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه دكتور كيف
تنظر الى هذه اللغه التي نسمعها من ممثل
الاتحاد الاوروبي في فلسطين وايضا من
الامين العام للامم المتحده
غوتيريش والمتحدث باسمه قال انه متمسك
بادانه السلوك الاسرائيلي في جنين
هذه لغه جيده ومفيده ولكنها غير كافيه على
الاطلاق لانه الذي نواجهه اليوم عدوان
خطير وشرس جدا
على فكره لم يتوقف هناك تقارير عن طائرات
تحلق حتى الان فوق مخيم جنين وقد يحاول
القيام بعمليات اغتيال جديده رد الفعل
الدولي لا يتناسب على الاطلاق مع حجم
الجريمه التي ارتكبت لا يتناسب مع حقيقه
مش هاي عدم توازن في استخدام القوه جيش
الاحتلال شن حرب على شعب تحت الاحتلال هو
يحتل هذه هي الجريمه الكبرى ولذلك هاي
جريمه حرب بما في ذلك الاعتداء على
المدنيين الفلسطينيين بهذا الشكل الوحشي
اضف على ذلك اننا نعيش مسلسل ليس فقط هذه
العمليه الهجوميه البربريه على مخيم جنين
قبل ذلك ارهاب المستوطنين في ترمس عيا وفي
صفاء وفي عريف وفي مناطق اخرى بحمايه جيش
الاحتلال وبالاضافه الى ذلك نحن خروقات
لحقوق الانسان لا اول لها ولا اخر حتى
عمليه اغتيال
الشاب اللي يعني كان مصاب باعاقه اياد
الحلاق برئ الجندي الذي قام بقتله كما لم
يحاكم اصلا من قام بقتل شيرين ابو عاقله
والطفله سديل غسان والطفل اللي عمره عامين
ونصف محمد التميمي سلسله من الجرائم
وسلسله من الخروقات لابسط حقوق الانسان
وبعد ذلك اعتداءات بالجيش على مخيم جنين
وعلى مناطق اخرى هذا الذي لا يتناسب لا
يردع لا يردع عفوا لا يردع الا بفرض
العقوبات على اسرائيل الكلام والبيانات
والادانات لا تعني شيئا لا لنتنياهو ولا
لحكومته ولذلك مطلبنا للعالم ان تفرض
عقوبات على اسرائيل والاتحاد الاوروبي
متقاعس في اتخاذ اجراءات عقابيه الولايات
المتحده منحازه بالمطلق لاسرائيل
وهي وبريطانيا بررت الجريمه بالقول انها
عمليه دفاعا وبالتالي دكتور لا تعتقد ان
الامر سيتعدى هذا المستوى دعنا نقول من
الادانه لما فعله الاسرائيليون
لن يتعدى على المستوى الرسمي ولكن الذي
يحدث على الصعيد الشعبي تحول هائل والفضل
الاول فيه لبطوله وصمود ومقاومه الشعب
الفلسطيني لو لم نكن نصمد ونكافح في ارض
وطننا ونقاوم هذا الظلم لما انتبه احد
الينا ولكن هذا الصمود وهذه المقاومه هي
التي تحدث تاثير تغيير يعني اخبرنا اكثر
ما الذي تعنيه بهذا التحول الكبير على
المستوى الشعبي
تحول كبير لانه هناك صعود لحركه المقاطعه
وفرض العقوبات على الصعيد الشعبي ضد
اسرائيل هناك تحول حتى في بلدان كالمانيا
حسب اخر استطلاعات الراي الثلثي الشعب
الالماني مؤيد للفلسطينيين على عكس مواقف
حكومتهم في الولايات المتحده كما ذكرت
سابقا 49% من اعضاء الحزب الديمقراطي
اصبحوا مؤيدين للفلسطينيين مقابل 36% فقط
لاسرائيل اذا هناك تحول عريض على الصعيد
الشعبي وطبعا هناك دول من نوع اخر مثل
جنوب افريقيا وغيرها التي تتضامن بشكل
مطلق مع الشعب الفلسطيني لكن عمليه التحول
ستجري وستتواصل بالضبط كما جرى في حاله
جنوب افريقيا ولكن اسرائيل لن ترضع لا
بالبيانات ولا بالاستنكارات سترضع بفرض
العقوبات عليها وما سيساعدنا على الصعيد
الدولي في هذا المجال لو تكون هناك
مبادرات ايضا على المستوى العربي لفرض هذه
المقاطعه على الحكومه الفاشيه الاسرائيليه
شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام لمبادر الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه
في هذه الاثناء اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مخيمه شعفاط شمال شرق القدس
المحتله واعتدت على المواطنين الفلسطينيين
وقامت باطلاق قنابل الغاز المسيده للدموع
عليهم بكثافه كما قامت بمطارده الشبان
الفلسطينيين والاعتداء عليهم من ناحيه
اخرى قالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان فتى
اصيب برصاصه اطلقها جنود الاحتلال قرب
الجدار الفاصله المقام في مدينه قلقيليه
شماليه الضفه الغربيه
وكان المئات من اهالي محافظه رام الله
والبيره قد شيعوا جثمان الشهيد عبد الجواد
حمدان صالح في قريه عروره شمال غرب رام
الله وجاب المشيعون شوارع القريه حاملين
جثمانه الملفوفه بالعالم الفلسطيني على
الاكتاف ورددوه هتافات المندده بجرائم
الاحتلال في حق الفلسطينيين كما شيعت
جماهيره غفيره جثمان الشهيد علاء قيسيه في
مدينه الظاهريه بمحافظه الخليل وسط اجواء
من الحزن والحداد
وكان عبد الجواد استشهد امس الجمعه بينما
استشهد على قيسيه في السادس والعشرين من
مايو ايار الماضي
[موسيقى]
نشرت كتيبه جنين تابعه لسرايا القدس
الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد مقطع فيديو
يظهر لحظه استهداف جرافه عسكريه اسرائيليه
بعبوه الناسفه خلال الاقتحام الاخير
لمدينه جنين ومخيمها وقالت كتيبه جنين ان
وحدتها الهندسيه الهندسيه فجرت عبوه
الناسفه من نوع طارق واحد في جرافه عسكريه
لجيش الاحتلال ضمن المعركه التي اطلقت
عليها اسم باس جنين
في السودان اعلن الجيش انه نفذ عمليه
نوعيه في ام درمان اسفلت عن مقتل عشرين من
المتمردين وتدمير اليات قتاليه كما قال من
جانب اخر قال مراسل الجزيره ان اشتباكات
وقعت بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
حول حي المهندسين ومحطه حمد النيل جنوبيه
[موسيقى]
هذا ونشرت منصات سودانيه صورا قالت انها
لتحرك مئات الجنود المتطوعين لدى القوات
المسلحه السودانيه من مدينه الدامر في
ولايه نهر النيل شماليه السودان باتجاه
العاصمه الخرطوم وذلك لمسانده الجيش في
المعارك التي يخوضها هناك ضد قوات الدعم
السريع
[موسيقى]
وقد افاد مراسل الجزيره بان طائرات تابعه
للقوات الجويه السودانيه حلقت صباح اليوم
بكثافه في سماء العاصمه وان قوات الدعم
السريع تصدت لها بالمضادات الارضيه شرقيه
الخرطوم في الاثناء قالت مصادر محليه
للجزيره ان قوات ان قوات من الدعم السريع
انتشرت في مناطق مختلفه عن طريق ابل على
طريق الصادرات الذي يربط اقليم دارفور
بالخرطوم
واضافت المصادر وان القوات نفسها تتمركز
في مدينه بارا ومدخل الطريق في مدينه
الاوبيض وكذلك غربيه ام درمان كما اشارت
الى ان قوات الدعم السريع تحاول بسيطرتها
على هذه الطرق قطع خطوط امداد الجيش
السوداني وتواصله مع مناطق رئيسيه في
دارفور وفي كوردوفان
من جانبها قالت قوات الدعم سريعنا الجيش
السوداني قصف عددا من الاحياء السكنيه
غربي ام درمان بالطائرات واضافت ان هجوم
الطيران العسكري على مربع 22 في دار
السلام مبده تسبب في مقتل اكثر من 31 شخصا
واصابه عشرات من المدنيين
هذا وصل وفد من القوه المدنيه السودانيه
الى العاصمه الاثيوبيه في اطار جوله له في
دول ايجاد وقال المتحدث باسم العمليه
السياسيه في السودان خالد عمر في تغريده
ان زياره الوفد تهدف للتواصل مع الفاعلين
السودانيين والاقليميين والدوليين من اجل
تسريع جهود احلال السلام في السودان
ويتزامن اصول الوفد مع انقاذ المجموعه
الرباعيه للدول ايجاد في اديس ابا يوم
الاثنين بمشاركه الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي بشان الازمه السودانيه
هذا وافاد مراسل الجزيره بوصول نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني الانتقاليه الى
العاصمه الارتريه اسمر في اول زياره له
لارتريا منذ توليه المنصب وسيجري عكار
مباحثات مع المسؤولين الارتريين واولهم
الرئيس السياسف ورقي وستتناول مستجدات
اوضاع الحرب في السودان والجهود الجاريه
لاحلال للسلام والاستقرار
[موسيقى]
اكدت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه اجانت يلن
ان الولايات المتحده والصين يجب ان
تتحاورا بشكل مباشر اذا كانت لديهما مخاوف
بشان ممارسات اقتصاديه جاء ذلك خلال
زيارتها المستمره الى بيجين قالت سابقا ان
فك الارتباط بين اكبر اقتصادين في العالم
مستحيل عمليا في المقابل دعا المسؤولون
الصينيون الى النظر للجانب المشرق في
العلاقات على الرغم من العواصف التي تمر
بها بينما قال نائب رئيس الوزراء الصيني
ان دعم علاقه اقتصاديه تنافسيه ووجود
قواعد عادله تحكم ذلك امر ضروري
وسائل عديده خرجت من ثنايا اجتماعات وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جانيت مع المسؤولين
الصينيين اكدت الوزيره ان الولايات
المتحده والصين اللتين وصفتهما بانهما
اكبر اقتصادين في العالم في حاجه ماسه
للتواصل عن كثب والتفاعل مع التحديات
الاقتصاديه العالميه وان ذلك يساعد على
فهم كامل للتوقعات الاقتصاديه العالميه
واتخاذ القرارات الافضل التي تعزز اقتصاد
البلدين
ان الولايات المتحده والصين باعتبارهما
اكبر اقتصادين في العالم عليهما التنافس
بشكل عادل والتواصل عن كثب لتجنب سوء
التفاهم
بينما دعا المسؤولون الصينيون الذين
اعترفوا بمرور علاقات البلدين بما سموه
بالعواصف الى النظر للجانب المشرق في
العلاقات ونوه نائب رئيس الوزراء الصيني
المسؤول عن الشؤون الاقتصاديه الى ضروره
بناء ودعم علاقه اقتصاديه تنافسيه ووجود
قواعد عادله تحكم ذلك
نامل ان يتخذ الجانب الامريكي موقفا
عقلانيا وعمليا ويلتقي بالصين في منتصف
الطريق للعمل معا والالتزام بالاجماع
المتفق عليه في اجتماع بالي بين رئيسي
الدولتين وتنفيذ توصياته كان اجتماع بالي
ذلك كالذي عقد في نوفمبر الماضي على هامش
قمه العشرين قد تحدث عن اداره الخلافات
والحيلوله دون التحول المنافسه الى صراع
ووضع قواعد امان لتحقيق ذلك
وشهدت علاقات البلدين بالفعل تحسن مؤقتا
ثم برزت ازمه اسقاط منطاد صيني داخل
الاجواء الامريكيه في يناير الماضي لتؤكد
الحاجه للكثير
بناء الثقه بين البلدين
على كل حال يسود التفاؤل اجتماعات الوزيره
الامريكيه الراهنه في الصين خاصه وانها
تاتي بعد وقت وجيز من زياره وزير الخارجيه
انطوني بلينكين واعرب نائب رئيس وزراء
الصين عن اسفه لما سماها حوادث غير متوقعه
اضرت بالعلاقات مشيرا لحادث من طاب لطالما
فرض التقاطعات التجاريه والسياسيه
والاقتصاديه واقعا معينا على علاقات
البلدين ورغم المخاوف والشكوك المتبادله
التي تكتنف تلك العلاقات فان الاعتقاد
السائد لديهما والذي تتم على ضوءه زياره
الوزيره الامريكيه الراهنه للصين هو ان
المصالح المشتركه تفرض عليهما التعاون
والتنسيق المتبادل
من بروكسل معنى تريزا فعلا مديره مركز
روسيا اوروبا واسيا للدراسات السيده فعلا
من خلال زياره وايضا هذه الزياره المستمره
لايام وزيره الخزانه
هل تعتقدين ان هناك نقاط التقاء وتفاهم
يمكن ان يصل اليها الطرفان وفق المصلحه
وماذا يمكن ان تكون هذه النقاط
العلاقات الروسيه
الصينيه الامريكيه وصلت الى ادنى مستوى
لها في السنوات الاخيره
ووزير الخارجيه ذهب الى هناك وكانت كان
البرود يخيموا على تلك العلاقات ولكن
اظهرت رغبتها في التعاون
والولايات الصين لديها تكنولوجيا متطوره
سوء استخدامها اثار توترا في العلاقات
والساده قالت انه ينبغي ان يتعلم كيف
يتعاونان وايضا يكون هناك استثمارات
الاقتصاد الصيني تراجع بشكل كبير بعد 19
والصين يحتاجون تحتاج الى المزيد من
الاستثمارات وهم يغيرون مواقفهم شيئا ما
ولكن هناك ثلاث ثلاثه مشاكل بين البلدين
وهي روسيا والحرب الاوكرانيه
وتايوان وايضا مشاكل تتعلق
بالتكنولوجيا المتطوره ونقل التكنولوجيا
الولايات المتحده تامل ان تتوصل الى
تفاهمات وان يكون استمر التعاون في تغير
المناخ اذا هناك مجالات قابله للتعاون
ولكن
الصين لديها
المزيد من
هي تبحث دائما عن وسائل لتحسين اقتصادها
وهناك امكانيه للتعاون في مجال تغيير
المناخ يعني نحن طبعا يمكننا ان نتحدث
كثيرا في هذا الموضوع ولكن وقتنا محدود
باختصار من فضلك كيف
يمكن ان يكون الحل من الناحيه الاقتصاديه
في الوقت الذي فيه احد اهم مخاوف الولايات
المتحده هو النمو الكبير كقوه اقتصاديه
للصين
لن تصل الى نسبه النمو التي تتجاوز 10%
لديهم بعض المشاكل
السكانيه
والاعمار
وكذلك الاسعار كثير من البلدان
تحاول ان تحد من المخاطر عند الاستثمار
سنرى بلدان اخرى
تتجه الى جنوب شرق اسيا والهند وماليزيا
لاستثمار فيها بدلا من الصين شكرا جزيلا
لك من بروكسل تريزا مديره مركز روسيا
اوروبا واسيا للدراسات
[موسيقى]
تظاهر عشرات المحتجين في العاصمه باريس
احياء لذكرى مقتل شاب على يد قوات الامن
الفرنسيه عام 2016 وجاءت المظاهره رغم
قرار السلطات الفرنسيه حضرها واعتبر
المتظاهرون ان قرار حظر المظاهره يمثل
خنقا للحريات في فرنسا ونددوا بعنف الشرطه
وعنصريتها
[موسيقى]
رغم المنع خرج المتظاهرون
لم يكتفوا بالوقوف في ساحه الجمهوريه في
باريس بل حور التظاهره الى مسيره تحد
لقرار المال
[موسيقى]
فشعارات ذاتها التي ترفع في هذه المسيره
ادانه العنف البوليسي والمطالبه بكشف
الحقيقه في مقتل ادم تراوري عام 2016 خلال
اعتقاله
شقيقته كعادتها لم تفوت الموعد طالبت
بالحقيقه كامله بل شككت في ديمقراطيه
بلدها بسبب قرار منع هذا
نسير ضد العنف البوليسي من اجل الحريه
والديمقراطيه اليوم حريتنا تتعرض للانتهاك
وفرنسا لا يمكنها ان تقول انها دوله
ديمقراطيه لقد منعونا من الاحتجاج منذ
ثلاثه ايام امتلات بالشرطه واليوم تشاهدون
الوجود الامنيه الكبيره حولنا
رغم الحضور الامني الكبير كان حرص الشرطه
كبيرا على عدم الاصطدام بالمتظاهرين فثم
نواب البرلمانيون من حزب فرنسا غير خاضعه
وصوره تعنيفهم ليست ما ينقص فرنسا في
الوقت الحالي وموقفهم ان الازمه عميقه
اكبر من مجرد حادث معزول
نائل ليس لوحده هناك كثيرون في مثل حالته
لكن تذكر ان الشرطه تتلقى الاوامر التي
تاتيها من اعلى هرم السلطه والتعامل مع
شبان الضواحي والاحياء الشعبيه هو نتيجه
للسياسات المقرره على اعلى مستوى في البلد
الشاب بنائي ما ادى الى موجه عنف غير
مسبوقه في فرنسا الان وقد هدات الاوضاع
نسبيا ما زال السؤال يطرح بشان سوء الفهم
الكبير بين فرنسا وضواحيها
[موسيقى]
ست ليالي من العنف ذكرت بان العلاقه بين
فرنسا وضواحيها ليست في احسن حالاتها بلغ
الوضع ان اصدرت اللجنه الامميه للقضاء على
التمييز العرقي بيانا قلقا مما قالت انه
استمرار للتنقيط العنصري في فرنسا وافراط
في استخدام العنف ضد الاقليات
[تصفيق]
لم ترق العباره للخارجيه الفرنسيه التي
ردت بان الامر ينطوي على مبالغات ونسيان
لاعمال العنف التي مست الافراد والمؤسسات
وعناصر الشرطه خلال ليالي العنف وايامه
لكن بغض النظر عن المواقف الدبلوماسيه
الصادره عن فرنسا فالرئيس ماكرون وان
اعتبر ان تهدئه الاوضاع الامنيه لها
الاولويه القصوى فقط طلب من حكومته
الانكباب على ما سماها الاسباب العميقه
لهذا التوتر
فالجميع يدرك ان هذه المشاهد التي عاشت
على وقعها فرنسا تسيء الى التماسك
الاجتماعي في الداخل والى صورتها في
الخارج محمد البقالي الجزيره باريس
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الهولندي مارك روت
استقاله حكومته بسبب ما قال انه فشل في
التوصل الى اتفاق بشان قضيه الهجره وقال
روتين ان حكومته الان هي حكومه تصريف
اعمال بانتظار اجراء انتخابات جديده
[موسيقى]
السجال بشان مساله طالبي اللجوء في هولندا
يحوم حول 46 الف طالب لجوء من المتوقع ان
يرتفع العدد الى سبعين الفا خلال العام
الجاري هذا الملف يشكل رافعه قويه لقوى
اليمين حيث يرى البعض ان استقاله
قدمت او قدمت على طبق من ذهب لليمني
خيرت
لاعادته للاضواء مره اخرى كما هو الحال في
هولندا يشكل ملف الهجره واللجوء منصه
للكثير من القوى اليمين في الكثير من
الدول الاوروبيه في اكتوبر الماضي وصلت
جورجيا مليوني جورجيا من لوني جوميلوني
زعيمه حزب اخوه ايطاليا الجذور القريبه من
الفاشيه وصلت لرئاسه الوزراء للمره الاولى
في فرنسا التي تشهد احداثا كبيره منذ ايام
يستمر حضور اليمين بارتفاع في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الاخيره حصلت مارلين لبان مرشحات
اقصى اليمين على 41 ونصف المئه من ببساطه
كان يمكن ان تتراس الحكومه
في العام الماضي فاز رئيس الوزراء المجري
فيكتور بالانتخابات للمره الرابعه وفي
خطاب له قال ان الاوروبيين مستعدون
للاختلاط فيما بينهم لكنهم لا يرغبون في
ان يصبحوا شعوبا متعدده الاعراق في السويد
بعد حزب الديمقراطي والسويد في اقصى من
اقصى اليمين في المرتبه الثانيه في دائره
التنافس السياسي في البلاد كما بات حزب
البديل من اجل المانيا اليميني الشعبوي
المعارض للهجره ثالث اقوى قوه برلمانيه
مستغلا الانتقادات الموجهه لسياسه الباب
المفتوح امام اللاجئين والتي ان انتهجت
خلالها ولايه انجيلا ميركل هذا الصعود
لليمين والتنافس السياسي داخل الدول جعل
من ملف الهجره واللجوء ملف خلاف اوروبي
ضمن اجتماعات تحاول اصلاح سياسه اللجوء
اهم بنود الاصلاح الذي اتفق عليه اولا
تتعلق باجراءات الحدود والعبور الى الدول
الاوروبيه الاخرى ومده الانتظار فكره
البلدان الثالثه
الامنه بين قوسين والتي تتضمن اعاده
المهاجرين الذين يعتبر طلب لجوهم غير
مقبول الى بلدان ثالثه تعتبر امنه والنقطه
الثالثه هي اعاده التوزيع والتعويضات حيث
سيطلب من الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
استقبال عدد معين من طالبي اللجوء ممن
يصلون للدول المعرضه لضغط الهجره وسيراعي
عدد سكان سيرعى عدد سكانها ونصيب الفرد من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي او ستقدم ستقدم
مساهمه ماليه لها
كتعويض من بروكسل الان ينضم الينا
وهو كبير الباحثين في مركز مارتنز
للدراسات الاوروبيه سيد نوفوتينيف الي اين
يتجه الامر مع كل هذا الحديث عن ملف
المهاجرين والى اي مدى
هذا الملف بالفعل يشكل رافعه لتعزيز موقع
اليمين واليمين المتشدد في القاره
الاوروبيه
حسنا
يمكن القول بان اعداد
المهاجرين الى اوروبا قد وصلت الى اعلى
مستوى لها ياتون الى اسبانيا والمانيا
والمخاوف
تزداد لانهم يطلبون العمل
وخاصه بعد ان ما مع عائلاتهم اليهم
مشكله اللاجئين تمثل
جزءا صغيرا من مشكله الهجره بشكل عام
وهناك مخاوف تتعلق
حول الهجره غير النظاميه
وكون الكثير منهم
ليس لا تتوفر فيهم شروط اللجوء
وهناك
دعم من وقفه من احزاب اليمين
هل هناك مقاومه كافيه يمكن ان تكبح هذا
التقدم اليميني برايك
لست متاكدا اعتقد
ان هناك
شعورا في الناخبين الاوروبيين الذين لا
يدعمون اليمين
او المعارضه
الاشتراكيه لكن في رايي ان احزاب اليمين
الوسط هي في موقف جيد
شكرا جزيلا لك
منوفتني كبير الباحثين في مركز مارتنز
للدراسات الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
لا يختار احد مغادره ارضه دون سبب الحروب
والنزاعات وتهديد الحياه كلها دوافع
للكثيرين للبحث عن موطن امن لهم ولاطفالهم
بطلب اللجوء اليوم بات هؤلاء ماده للسجال
السياسي في كثير من الدول وباتو رافعه
ومنصه لاصوات متطرفه تبحث عن سبب وان كان
مصطنعا لفرز الاخر ورفضه نهايه الحصاد
الليله شكرا لكم وتصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]